yeah get some energy man what's up gq my
name is quincy isaiah and these are my
10 essential items
[Music]
let's see what we have right here i have
the first uh live show i ever did in
college it was called sketching edge it
was a sketch comedy show we did two
nights sold out both of them started my
journey of doing shows in college i was
able to go see the lion king going into
my senior year and that was the first
broadway show i was able to see led into
the thing that
got me to this place right now raising
in the sun which is a script i used in
college and you got like all the notes
and uh my highlights this one i knew i
wanted to act so this book means a lot
to me prior to doing the raisin i was
actually majored in business and going
into my senior year that's when i
switched my major from business to
theater this is when i knew that i made
a good decision after the second night i
believe i went to the lobby and i got a
standing ovation in the lobby the
feeling of just
that i was able to touch people and
affect people i think was really
what i fell in love with thank you
lorraine hansberry for writing such a
beautiful story
from mr john c riley himself dr jerry
bust it's a replica of the actual lakers
1980 championship with love from jcr
just being a
a part of such a great group and a great
cast and a great crew the ring
shows that you know we won the
championship because we was the best
it's the best show on tv right now i'm
biased but
i said it so that's what i feel
this right here is getting inside the
mind of a young quincy when i really got
into acting and start understanding the
craft of it and again just my thoughts
and all the plays that i was able to see
in college that i was able to use as
fuel
to get to this point after i graduated
college i moved out here to l.a went on
auditions a lot of auditions most of the
stuff that i actually booked was unpaid
luckily i was able to get an agent using
those reels this journal shows when you
focus on the work that's where you can
not be scared of like what's gonna
happen when i look through this journal
and just like see where my thoughts were
and where my head was during this time i
set myself up to get to this point and
i'm not gonna let myself down
without uh without a fight this journal
actually
lives in my nightstand right next to my
bed i don't i don't look at it that
often but i know it's there it's about
setting goals and and figuring it out
from there
[Applause]
what do we have here
moisturizing lip balm playing magic they
ask me to like smile a lot naturally i
smile a lot anyway but when you when you
playing magic you gotta smile a lot
bigger and when you smile your lips can
crack sometimes to keep the lips nice
and moisturized so they don't get
chapped i thank you
burt's bees for keeping my lips from
bleeding on my co-stars
this might be one of the most important
items on the list because it holds all
my other items my bag
somebody got it for me when uh we came
back for season one to shoot the rest of
the nine episodes so we shot the first
episode in 2019 shot the last nine in
2021 and i didn't think i would use it
because like i love bags like i love a
good backpack a strong sturdy backpack
but i was like maybe it's a little too
flashy but then i started using it
and i was like
nah it's just flashy enough so i get
compliments on it all the time
it's my travel size smell good bond
number nine i was actually uh dating
somebody and i was told that i needed a
signature smell i can't get enough of it
and i hope that they send me some more i
really enjoy it and it's from new york i
love new york i hear i give really good
hugs and i think this has a little bit
of something to do with it so
it's my epic curing for my face without
being uh compliments you're glowing like
what's happened i try and use it every
day
uh wash my face get out the shower i
spray my little mist
and close them pores and then i slap
this on there
my skin carrying routine has definitely
evolved much like
my smell good game take care of your
body you gotta put lotion on your hands
put moisturize on your face put
deodorant under your arms i've grown in
my skincare routine and i have a lot of
people to thank for that one of the main
ones was uh corinne she was the makeup
artist on our show and like my face
would break out a lot and she got me
this stuff and this is what kind of
helped clear it up and i've been
sticking with it ever since
we got some knowledge this is the book
that i'm currently reading this is one
that i'm really trying to sit down and
break into it's told me how to take
things personal some people have bad
days and some people have good days and
regardless of how they treat you is
is not a reflection of you is a
reflection of them and where they are in
their life i can't even speak to that on
uh the show first episode devon nixon
playing his dad norm nixon whooped
magic's butt in a one-on-one game and i
felt like i was getting my butt hooked
and i didn't like that feeling i didn't
take it personally and i understood that
it was about to work it's another gift i
got from my nutritionist water bottle
stay hydrated especially when you out
here moving around and 14 hours on set
it's good to have one of these close by
i notice if i don't drink enough water
i'm not focused you can use it as a
weapon if need be
it keeps your water nice and cold or
nice and hot depending on how you like
your water hey if you like hot water
you're weird so
that's on you
it's my laptop this thing right here
this
great block of technology i actually
just got this too because my my old one
died on me but i had it like 10 years so
hopefully this one lasts another 10
years and this is what a lot of work
gets done on read a lot of scripts on
this thing whatever i need to do is
happening probably on this be productive
which i'm not always but when i am being
productive is probably on this thing
right here thank you all for watching i
hope you all enjoy my essentials peace